I love the power glove it's so bad the
wizard why am i reviewing the wizard cuz
I saw it as a kid and I thought I was
cool and I was perusing Netflix and I
was like alright what to watch it oh my
god that's the wizard in hi-def I'm
watching it that I watched it and ilish
it so the Wizards a movie they came out
like 1989 and it's the story of Fred
Savage who wants to run away from home
and his brother who's just really
traumatized cakes he saw something
really traumatizing when he was like a
younger kid and he's like kind of
autistic because he's really good at
video games he's like the Rain Man for
video games in fact this whole movie is
like Rain Man for kids so they run
across this girl who I am pretty sure is
the inspiration for Hermione herself and
this girl's like oh there's this big
video game tournament in LA and if your
brother wins he wins $50,000 we'll all
split it so when I was watching I was
like okay there's more of a payoff for
this kid to win this video game
tournament in this movie and Eminem to
win the last rap battle in eight mile I
mean Eminem got like street cred but
this kid gets 50 large go that kid so
after that we embarked on the biggest
road trip for kids and most elaborate
two-hour commercial for Nintendo that's
exactly what this movie was I know it is
a commercial because it is not great and
they're not good actors you watch it now
you're like who says these lines like I
love the power glove it's so bad that's
a real line in a movie YouTube that [ __ ]
what's really funny to pick out is
they're playing arcade games and like
7-elevens and stuff but on screen is the
NES version of that game propaganda let
me tell you and there's a scene where
the kids are like oh we need a lot of
money how are we gonna do it oh well
shark those guys and they look over and
there's like three fifty year old
businessmen and button ups and ties all
playing in arcade games that's never
happened in the history of life and
there's a scene with this one kid he's
like the Johnny type character from
Karate Kid for this movie he's showing
off his badass skill to show that he's
better than this kid he's the one who
delivers lines like I loved the power
Club it's so bad but I knew it was
[ __ ] because they were actually
playing a Nintendo Nintendo it
old-school Nintendo and the scene did
not start out with anyone going that's
what I knew it was actually Nintendo
propaganda yeah not the 9000 scenes
before that and then an hour and a half
of that acting and not as fun nostalgia
as I remember they finally get to the
tournament in which after that is not
only a Nintendo commercial but a
Universal Studios commercial also you
see King Kong the riot
that scene ruined the magic for me when
I was a kid I was like why do I want to
see the behind the scenes stuff that the
King Kong writer just now I know it's
fake when I was a kid my I thought it
was real shut up
and then they square off with the big
unveiling to Super Mario Brothers 3 yeah
Super Mario Brothers 3 didn't come out
before this movie came out so this movie
was like the unveiling of Super Mario
Brothers 3 see the coolest Nintendo
advertisement of all time the wizard but
now Super Mario Brothers 3 has not only
come out now we have Super Mario Galaxy
and a hundred other things so the
nostalgia that I felt when I was a kid
is probably not going to be shared by
the masses of today if you are an
old-school video game or like old-school
Nintendo video gamer there's gonna be
parts of this movie where you're like
that's awesome I remember that [ __ ] if
you are anyone else you're gonna be like
what's the point of this shitty movie
with horrible acting and how do these
actors go on to do anything else I think
two of them did it's all rephrase it's
not Rain Man for kids it's Rain Man for
80s kids I will say it's probably a good
time if you are an old-school Nintendo
video gamer and you watch it drunk and
as party against lay the game's faces
the game so it will appeal to a very
specific demographic but if you're part
of that demographic
you'll still not like the movie they'll
be part of you that will but if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you